hi happy pizza m'as it has been a tough
few weeks I mean it's been a tough year
even for my cat and she doesn't really
understand celebrity deaths or politics
she is more of a philosophy and golf
kind of gal my name is Lex I have a
youtube channel but more importantly I
have this cat her name is Felicity she's
been an indoor cat all her life she's
nine years old and I adopted her about a
month ago she's very friendly she likes
being stroked and sitting on laps and
the other night at about 3 a.m. she
decided to scoot her butt across my bed
sheet I guess it was itchy and then I
forgot and I slept on it
the she know her butthole but at this
point in terms of hygiene there's
basically no difference there are a lot
of great things about owning a cat great
for me selfish she gives me a sense of
routine and purpose she makes me
responsible for someone other than
myself which in turn makes me more
responsible for myself because I have to
remember to do things like clean up my
living space and not leave old food just
on the ground
she really relaxes me a cat is basically
like a furry hot water bottle with a
face if you picture that literally it's
not very relaxing I mean also she's just
so cute oh my god it's physically
painful please make her leave the room
my cat gets stuff out of this - food
shelter water the power trio catnip so
regular access to legal highs and an
owner who like the parent of a newborn
of the Gowan Hank has committed to the
fact that they will not get a good
night's sleep for a very long time so I
don't mind that she likes to be the
little spoon or that she wakes me up in
the middle of the night although she has
to bail at this great trick where she
reaches out about 2:00 a.m. and punches
me in the face to try and get me to wake
up and Stroke her it's so adorable the
more I think about it though the more
it's weird that I've brought this animal
into my home she's domesticated
obviously if I don't think that my
bedroom is necessarily her natural
habitat I really don't want to delve
into the horrifying depths of the indoor
versus outdoor cat conversation people
yell there but as Flis has now been
outside and she's a bit more senior she
would be in a lot of trouble if I just
open the front door and said go run be
free my child good luck with the big
metal dogs with wheels if they've never
known anything different do you think
they're just like cool this is the world
I'm gonna eat some treats given to me by
the big stupid talking noodle what does
my cat look at the very large tool
climbing tree that I bought her and
think like what what are you trying to
pull
that is not a tree something I do find
interesting is the difference in
lifespan I looked up a lifespan of a
rabbit and it said eight to twelve years
domesticated one to two years in the
wild in the wild animals are fighting
for food mates survival sometimes it's
cold they can have untreated illnesses
and injuries predators are always given
them heck nobody lets them eat a small
bit of cheese if they've been good that
day
is it better to have a long comfortable
life that's not necessarily instinctive
to you or to have a short natural one
where you run free terrified with no
idea what cheese even is I am of course
just talking about domesticated animals
obviously not like orcas in a tank I
guess you could say that humans weren't
really supposed to live inside though
someone was like hey I put a rug down in
this cave you should come in here
because it's um it's better
someone fact-check that for me a big
problem has come from my love of pets is
over breeding we are creating a huge
overpopulation problem that often leads
to animals being without homes that's
why animal charities always encourage
you to spay and neuter your pets and to
adopt rather than shop if you're
thinking of getting an animal
people think rescue animals are so
damaged and difficult but Flis is not
damaged or difficult although I have
taught her to high-five but she refuses
to distinguish between the high five and
the low five that's the same thing plus
it's the same I think my cat is very
happy here with me and I can't go back
in time and undo the domestication of
pets so I am happy to give what a loving
home it was the first person to look at
animals especially like wild cats and
wolves and go yeah I want that guy
licking yoga off my hand I don't have
the answer to any of these questions
maybe you do thank you for joining me
here on vlogbrothers during Pizza mmus
and for sticking with me when I decided
I just wanted to make a video about cats
I've been on the world wide web for a
while I know what you kids like John
I'll see you on Tuesday I've always
wanted to say that